Off the coast of Brazil is an island so dangerous
that the Brazilian Navy has expressly forbidden anyone from landing there
and you should definitely listen to them
Locals love to recount two grisly stories about this island
in one a local fisherman wants to pick some bananas
gets out onto this island
and within minutes he is bitten by a snake
he runs back and jumps in his boat but its too late
as he paddles away, he passes out
and is found when the boat washes upshore
with him lying in a pool of his own blood
the second story is about a lighthouse keeper
who lived on this island with his
one night they made the disastrous mistake of leaving the window open
and through that window climbed a dozen snakes
they bit everyone in the family
and they died there, inside the lighthouse
You’ll see a theme in these stories
that’s because this island, Ilha de Queimada Grande
is also known as snake island
this small island miles off the coast of Brazil
is the highest density of poisonous snakes on the planet
researchers estimate that there is one deadly snake for every square meter
that means you are never farther than three feet from death
the snakes are only on this island, they are an endemic species
it is part of the Lancehead genus which is
responsible for over 90% of the snake bite fatalities in Brazil
and they are notorious for loving to hang out in the trees
it’s not just that snakes are underfoot they are also overhead
you are in a three dimensional matrix of death by snake
this particular snake, this Golden Lancehead
is one of the most venomous snakes on the planet
the way the venom effects you is it
begins to necrotize and corrupt your flesh from the inside out
you basically start to melt.
Should you get bitten
you have a maximum, and this is an absolute maximum
to get somewhere and get the antidote
however it’s just as likely that you’ll be dead in an hour
so like don’t plan on a six, your like “Ahh it’ll only take me five hours to get to the hospital
no, you are in so much trouble
what are you doing on this island in the first place, actually?
don’t go there!
unfortunately researcher believe the snake population
on the island has decreased by as much as 50%
originally they were as high as five snakes per square meter
which is just like, there’s just snakes
the island is made of snakes
and this is in large part due to poachers
people who are going to the island
with the express purpose of stealing these snakes
because they are so unique in the world
they can fetch anywhere between ten and thirty thousand dollars
so despite the terror of snake island
the truth is, with the population of Golden Lancehead's in decline
the snakes have a lot more to fear from us
than we do from them
we can just stay off the island
which we should
because it’s full of snakes!
Subscribe here
and watch more videos here
Ssssss, ahhhh, ahhhh! My god! No! Why did I go to this island?!!